hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Rockstar Games have whet our appetites
with a second trailer for Red Dead
Redemption 2 in the 92nd preview we've
seen a few of the activities will be
undertaking and whereabouts the story
fits in with the original so here are 6
things we've noticed in the latest Red
Dead Redemption 2 trailer I'm probably
going to draw a few parallels with the
original Red Dead so I'll put a link
on-screen now for a three-minute recap
of that story if you need a refresher
let's start off with the outlaw we'll be
filling the boots of arthur morgan
you're a wanted man mr. morgan from what
we've seen of morgan he is a no-nonsense
criminal who is happy to intimidate to
get an advantage maybe when your
mother's finished mourning your father
i'll keep her in black on your behalf
he's capable with a bow and can dual
wield pistols with the best of them
morgan is a member of dutch mandolins
gang if you remember the original story
of Red Dead Redemption you'll know that
Dutch was the main outlaw we were
hunting down with our beloved John
Marston Dutch is looking much younger
here so it's safe to say this is a
prequel to the events of the original
Red Dead although it's a little harder
to define whereabouts Red Dead Revolver
falls into this universe I wonder if
we'll meet John Marston or red hallow in
the gang wishful thinking maybe by the
way do you have any ideas who this lady
could be I first thought she was Abigail
Marston John's wife but they just don't
look alike she actually looks quite
similar to Bonnie but that can't be
right can it so what kind of things can
we expect from running with Dutchess
ragtag gang of criminals already heists
and bank jobs are hinted at on the scale
that GTA 5 has also custom to even a
train heist looks to be on the cards
smaller activities like hunting look to
be back to and getting the old lasso out
and taming a horse is here as well
although we haven't seen the official
map father game a recently depicts a
simply humongous plan that leaks seems
to have been confirmed as the trailer
reveals changes in the ecosystem this
could be seasonal change
geez but with the Rocky Mountains
covered in snow over to the swampy marsh
lands and the bright sunny areas this
look to be continuing what we saw in the
original game but with far more vigour
detail and grandeur and finally we have
an updated release date which will
probably change again very soon as
Rockstar only release a product when
they are good and ready
love it or hate it a finished high
quality game next year is a far better
prospect that are brushed released this
year Red Dead Redemption 2 will release
in spring 2018 so that's somewhere in
between March and May
so that's where we stand with Red Dead
Redemption - with less than six months
until launch more information will
probably arrive at PlayStation
experience in December Rockstar and
Playstation have built a relationship
around Brett dead - so expect early
access or maybe exclusive missions or
items for PlayStation users by the way
the trailer has been confirmed to be
running on the PlayStation 4 so what do
you think - Red Dead Redemption - are
you ready to go back to the Wild West
did you play the original I'm hoping for
the character switch mechanic from GTA 5
robbing a train switching between each
gang member could be insanely good is
that a pipe dream I hope not I imagine
from PlayStation grenades is been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
you